[Musik]
im fünften jahrhundert vor christus
hielten während der schlacht bei den
thermopylen 300 spartaner tage lang
durch den ansturm von etwa 200.000
persischen soldaten stand
heute 2500 jahre später gibt es auch ein
kleines land mit der gleichen
philosophie des widerstands der
entschlossenheit um der mobilisierungs
bereitschaft seiner bevölkerung
und nein so überraschend es für unsere
tollen zuschauer auch sein mag geräten
diesmal nicht über israel
[Musik]
denn es gibt ein land das noch stärker
militarisiert ist als die einzige
demokratie des nahen ostens die ihre
existenz einzig und allein ihre extremen
wehrhaftigkeit verdankt welches land
markt dies nur sein okay es steht ja
schon im titel dieses videos heute
sprechen wir über singapur
aber nicht über jene seiten singapur ist
die wir alle kennen und lieben sondern
über das am wenigsten bekannte singapur
dass militante kraftstrotzende
furchteinflößende singapur genau heute
werden wir euch das sparta des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
vorstellen also lasst uns loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
singapur ist ein kleines land ein sehr
kleines land im grunde genommen ein
winziges land obwohl es weniger als
sechs millionen einwohner zählt und nur
7 130 quadratkilometer klein ist das ist
weniger als berlin ist singapur eine
militärmacht ja du hast richtig gehört
wir sprechen von einer erstklassigen
militärmacht die es selbstständig mit
fast jedem land der welt aufnehmen
könnte
denn es hat sich herausgestellt dass
singapur über eine der besten
ausgerüstete streitkräfte der welt
verfügt in den streitkräften des
modernen stadtstaats dienen mehr als
70.000 vollzeit angehörige etwa 400.000
teilzeitkräfte und mehr als 1,2
millionen militärisch ausgebildete
reservisten
wenn ja in singapur gibt es eine
zweijährige wehrpflicht für alle männer
die ns genannt wird auf diese weise
machen die regulären streitkräfte ob
vollzeit oder teilzeit acht prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung aus die militärisch
ausgebildete und verfügbare wertige
bevölkerung gar ein viertel der gesamten
einwohnerzahl und das ist noch nicht
alles seit 2015 gibt es in diesem land
auch eine freiwilligenarmee das
singapore armed forces volunteer chor
dass auch frauen offen steht und eine
mitgliedschaft bis zum alter von 45
jahren erlaubt
wenn wahrscheinlich keinem anderen land
der welt ist die bevölkerung so stark in
die streitkräfte eingebunden und das
alles ist nur die spitze des eisbergs
wie er wahrscheinlich schon aus ziel
unserer videos west ist in der modernen
kriegsführung die anzahl der verfügbaren
soldaten nicht das wichtigste element
welches über sieg und niederlage
entscheidet denn über die truppenstärke
hinaus sind die verfügbare technologie
und die militärische ausrüstung
entscheidend
[Musik]
singapur ist heute eines der
wohlhabendsten länder der welt und hat
in den letzten jahrzehnten auch in
dieser hinsicht eben nicht gespart aber
jetzt haltet euch fest der kleine
stadtstaat des namens tritt also als in
der stufe 4 bedeutet die löwenstadt
verfügt doch tatsächlich über mehr
kampfflugzeuge als die luftstreitkräfte
von ländern wie kanada schweden oder den
niederlanden und was deren schlagkraft
angeht übertrifft er sogar länder wie
spanien
wir sprechen hier von hochmoderner
ausrüstung aus den besten
rüstungsschmieden der usa israels und
europas tatsächlich war singapur das
erste land in ganz südostasien in
welches das kampfflugzeug der fünften
generation erste von 30 in die hände
bekam wie du dir sicher vorstellen
kannst ist der militärhaushalt dieses
landes nicht gerade klein fallen wenn
man bedenkt dass dort weniger als sechs
millionen einwohner leben in der tat
über steigen die militärausgaben im jahr
2021 11,5 milliarden dollar das ist fast
das dreifache des budgets des
nachbarlandes malaysia und 25 prozent
mehr als die militärausgaben von
indonesien einem land mit der 46 fachen
bevölkerungszahl um das ganze mal in die
richtige perspektive zu rücken reden
hier über einen verteidigungshaushalt
der dem eines so bedrohten staates wie
taiwan entspricht ziemlich erstaunlich
nicht wahr
singapur ist ein sehr wohlhabendes land
mit hoher rechtssicherheit
es ist eine jener enklaven in denen das
kapital von millionen von investoren und
unternehmen aus der ganzen welt landet
dieser status könnte die
begehrlichkeiten anderer länder wecken
und muss daher geschützt werden und
anhand der vorliegenden daten sehen wer
das sich singapur über diese tatsache
sehr sehr im klaren es ist
seit seiner unabhängigkeit im jahr 1965
hat dieses kleine asiatische land drei
militärstrategien verfolgt drei
strategien die ihre wahrnehmung der welt
erklären und die ihre relativ großen und
gut ausgerüstete streitkräfte im laufe
der jahre geprägt haben
[Musik]
denn nichts von dem was wir euch erzählt
haben ist zufall hört zu
[Musik]
der vergiftete schirm
die erste militärstrategie singapurs
große verteidigungsstrategie entstand
kurz nach der unabhängigkeitserklärung
unter den berühmten liquor new den
erster premierminister der das heutige
singapur und war vor 20 jahre lang
regiert nach der unabhängigkeit von
großbritannien singapur zunächst in eine
föderation mit malaysia ein wurde jedoch
nach massiven unruhen zwischen
chinesischen und nicht klinischen
einwohnern und heftigen ideologischen
konflikten mit der zentralregierung in
kuala lumpur finden nur zwei jahren
wieder aus der föderation ausgeschlossen
die willensnation musste fortan und ihre
wirtschaftliche unabhängigkeit kämpfen
und sah sich mit problemen die
massenarbeitslosigkeit knappheit an
wohnraum ackerland und grundlegenden
rohstoffen wie erdöl konfrontiert
premierminister liu war von anfang an
klar dass die verteidigung der
hoheitlichen grenzen für das überleben
singapur ist unabdingbar war eine idee
die er 1966 in einem seiner bekanntesten
zitate sehr deutlich zum ausdruck
brachte in einer welt in der die großen
fische kleine fische und die kleinen
fische shrimps fressen muss singapur ein
giftiger stimmt werden wenn du ihn ist
kommst du verdauungsbeschwerden iq als
league one you diese worte sprach
unterschied sich die situation singapur
es grundlegend von seinem heutigen
status damals was singapur ein armes
land das kaum verbündete hat er zum teil
von feindlichen nachbarn umgeben war und
in einer welt überleben musste die durch
den kalten krieg in zwei hälften geteilt
war die löwenstadt musste in der lage
sein sich selbst zu verteidigen das ziel
war das eine invasion dieser enklave so
viel geld menschenleben und militärische
ressourcen kosten solle dass kein land
in versuchung käme auch nur an sie zu
denken
singapurs verteidigungskräfte mussten in
der lage sein den feind so viel schaden
die möglichst zuzufügen selbst wenn es
ihnen gelänge die stadt zu übernehmen in
diesem fall wurde singapur zum
sprichwörtlichen vergifteten schwimmt
werden
diese strategie ist übrigens sehr stark
derjenigen welche viele analysten teil
waren ans herz legen wenn es sich
erfolgreich gegen china verteidigen will
wir haben darüber bereits ein sehr
populäres video gedreht falls du es
nicht gesehen hast kannst du es über den
link in der beschreibung oder das symbol
oben rechts finden und vergiss bitte
auch nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren
und das glocken symbol zu aktivieren
damit du keines unserer spannenden
videos mehr verpasst ich danke dir die
frage ist nun auf welchem weg man in der
praxis erreichen kann dass ein land zum
vergifteten schwimmt wird zu einer
militärischen giftpille
nun im grunde durch drei dinge in dem
man sich bis an die zähne bewaffnet sich
maximal auf den kampf vorbereitet und
mächtige freunde findet das problem war
nur zum zeitpunkt seiner
unabhängigkeitserklärung verfügte der
stadtstaat singapur gerade mal über zwei
kaum einsatzbereite infanterie bataillon
und eine alte kanone von panzern
kriegsschiffen oder gar kampfflugzeuge
keine spur
die streitkräfte mussten praktisch
komplett aus dem nichts aufgebaut werden
um dies zu erreichen hat halt der ligue
un ju seinem innen- und
verteidigungsminister gates wie einen
geheimen auftrag singapur sollte
beziehungen zu israel ägypten und indien
aufbauen und weißt du was von diesen
drei ländern kann die überschwängliche
reaktion ausgerechnet aus israel denn
das junge land suchte damals auch
verzweifelt nach internationalen
verbänden sowie israel nicht nur einer
der ersten staaten wie singapur
anerkannt wird sondern auch im oktober
1965 kommt zwei monate nach der
ausrufung der unabhängigkeit war die
armee des hebräischen starts bereits
dabei die streitkräfte des neuen landes
aufzubauen aber natürlich ging das nicht
einfach so
die zusammenarbeit zwischen diesen
beiden ländern musste so diskret wie
möglich erfolgen niemand durfte von ihr
erfahren warum nun decken mal einen
moment darüber nach von welchen beiden
ländern der kleine stadtstaat umgeben
ist malaysia und indonesien zwei große
muslimische länder die damals die
praktisch alle islamischen länder israel
im fadenkreuz hatten wenn singapur also
nicht als feindliches element angesehen
werden und gefahr laufen wollte eine
islamische invasion zu rechtfertigen
musste es erfinderisch sein sie dem
erfolgende ist an die ersten
militärberater die von israel nach
singapur geschickt wurden hießen
mexikaner um dieses krieg zu sein um
diese operation so glaubwürdig wie
möglich zu machen wählte israel
mitglieder seiner streitkräfte aus die
aufgrund ihrer gesichtszüge als
mexikaner durchgehend konnten die
entsandten soldaten und offiziere
dürften also keine blonden und
blauäugigen hünen seien von dieser
besondere anekdote erzählt league on you
selbst in seinen 1998 veröffentlichten
memoiren
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass aus dieser
zusammenarbeit das sogenannte braun burg
hervorging ein masterplan der vom
damaligen stellvertretenden leiter reha
wie geleitet wurde ich möchte dass du
nicht an mehrere dinge erstens wir haben
nicht vor singapur in eine israelische
kolonie zu verwandeln der aufgabe ist es
in den soldatenberuf beizubringen sie
auf die beine zu stellen damit sie ihre
eigene armee führen können er geht nicht
dorthin um ihnen befehle zu erteilen
sondern um sie zu beraten und drittens
ihr seid keine waffenhändler wenn die
empfehlungen für die beschaffung von
waffen aussprechen solltet ihr euch auf
euer professionelles militärisches
urteilsvermögen verlassen sabine israels
ehemaliger generalstabschef und
premierminister
[Musik]
und so entwickelten die israelis in nur
drei monaten eine ganze militär
strategie und doktrin deren zentrale
achse darin bestand eine bürger armee
aus wehrpflichtigen aufzubauen die von
einer kleinen hochprofessionellen und
gut ausgerüsteten regulären truppen
ausgebildet und geführt werden sollte
[Musik]
erinnert sich diese strukturen etwas
genauer es ist exakt das gleiche modell
das auch heute noch in kraft ist das
konzept der israelis scheint sich also
bewährt zu haben
um ihr ziel zu erreichen und das land
hast du zu bringen in weniger als einem
jahr zählt zwölf bataillone zur
verteidigung der stadt in
einsatzbereitschaft zu haben wurde die
wehrpflicht eingeführt damit sollte
sichergestellt werden dass die gesamte
nation im bedarfsfall mobilisiert werden
kann und dass diese enorme kapazität die
große bastion zur verteidigung der stadt
sein sollte aber als das land reicher
wurde und die streitkräfte besser
ausgerüstet und ausgebildet waren wurde
klar dass diese militär strategie ein
update nötig hatte dieser moment kam in
den 1980 er jahren und von diesem
zeitpunkt an entwickelte sich singapur
wollen diesen soliden grundlagen
ausgehend und dank seiner militärischen
vision zu einer großen militärmacht also
aufgepasst werden jetzt wirds erst
richtig spannend
stachelschweine delfine und eine
brüllende löwe nur anderthalb jahrzehnte
diesen kurzen zeitraum braucht es
singapur um von einer verarmten fischer
kolonie ohne armee zu einem staat zu
erwerben in der lage war über seine
eigenen territorialen grenzen hinaus
militärisch handlungsfähig zu sein und
genau dies wurde zur grundlage der
zweite militär strategie der löwenstadt
der sogenannten stachelschwein strategie
die anfang der 1980 er jahre umgesetzt
wurde und einen gewaltigen wandel
besagte singapur musste nun nicht mehr
annehmen das ist überfallen werden
könnte auch wenn dies mit hohen kosten
verbunden war darum ging es ja
eigentlich bei der idee des vergifteten
schrems sie verfügt nun über
ausreichende ausbildung und ausrüstung
und ihr passives verteidigungs modell in
einen viel aktiveres umzuwandeln diese
doktrin gibt bis zum beginn des neuen
jahrhunderts in kraft und war der
notwendige schritt um den aufbau einer
modernen armee zu vollenden
und so wurde singapur nach der
stachelschwein doktrin nicht nur zu
einem wichtigen kunden der
us-amerikanischen israelischen und
europäischen rüstungsindustrie was dem
stadtstaat an sich schon enormen
einfluss verschaffte sondern entwickelte
auch seine eigene lokale
rüstungsindustrie eine industrie die
singapur zu einem der 30 größten
waffenexporteur der welt gemacht hat
gemessen am handelsvolumen zu den
erfolgreichsten rüstungsgüter singapurs
gehören das sturmgewehr s21 das
militärische geländefahrzeug bronkow und
es gibt teils hatte transportfahrzeug
terrex sowie eine vielzahl von drohnen
und haubitzen aller art und das ist noch
nicht das ende der fahnenstange singapur
wendet derzeit seine dritte strategie an
die sogenannte delfin doktrin löwen
shrimps stachelschweine und delfinen ich
komme mir vor wie in einer natur doku
aber im ernst diese die analogien sind
ja kein zufall sondern sollen die
charakteristika der strategien zum
ausdruck bringen warum also nun der
delfin nun der delfin ist ein
unglaublich wendiges tier das seine
wendigkeit aber dazu nutzen kann haie
anzugreifen obwohl er nicht so stark ist
wie sie und genau das ist die idee der
militärstrategie singapur im rahmen
dieser doktrin bauen sie eine
beeindruckte luftwaffe auf die sehr
starken sehr agil ist um jeder bedrohung
zuvorkommen zu können mit anderen worten
singapur will die totale
luftüberlegenheit in der region
erreichen und um diese enormen reaktions
und antizipation fähigkeiten zu
erreichen hat der derzeitige
premierminister lee hsien long einen
ehrgeizigen plan ins leben gerufen um
die gesamte militärstruktur an diese
neue aufgabe anzupassen
zu den wichtigsten aspekten der neue
strategie gehören der ersatz der
alternde flotte durch f 35b der fünften
generation sowie die erneuerung und
erweiterung der marine flotte die
derzeit sechs mehrzweck fregatten auf
basis der französischen lafarge klasse
betreibt es geht auch um die anschaffung
von schlüssel waffen die deutschen
leopard panzern der zweiten generation
einheimischen hunter kampfflugzeugen die
seit 2009 10 in betrieb sind um den
us-amerikanischen lockheed martin m 142
heimers raketenwerfer von dem singapur
bereits zwei dutzend einheiten besitzt
so wurde singapur erst zu einer
militarisierten stadt dann zu einer
uneinnehmbaren festung und jetzt zu
einem militärischen akteur mit der
maxime die beste verteidigung kann ein
guter angriff sein
[Musik]
aber warte mal denn dieses gewaltige
arsenal ist nur ein element der
verteidigungs macht singapurs es stärkt
nämlich zurzeit wieder wie schon seit
vielen jahren die militärischen
synergien mit seinen verbündeten
insbesondere durch militärische
ausbildung sind auch soldaten trainieren
derzeit in so unterschiedlichen ländern
wie den usa australien thailand taiwan
und südafrika und nehmen häufig an
grossangelegten militärischen
verteidigungs übungen teil darüber
hinaus hat die löwenstadt auch wichtige
verteidigungsabkommen mit angriffs-
angeschlossen welche unter anderem
us-soldaten den zugang zu ihren
militärbasen ermöglichen
singapur erneuert militärbasen pakt mit
den usa ermitteln sich vertiefen der
verteidigungs beziehungen mit china
washington erneut den vertrag der den
us-streitkräften den zugang zu den
stützpunkten in der löwenstadt bis 2035
gewährt und unterstreicht damit die
bedeutung des stadtstaates für amerikas
asien strategie der versteuerung der
staatschef die queue sagte einmal er
habe nichts dagegen dass sowohl die usa
als auch china eines tages über
logistische basen in seinem land
verfügen würden
marine steigt achte von 21 ländern
beginnen mit us-geführten übungen in
südostasien sie kennt man ihn finden in
singapur vor ort als auch virtuell statt
peking und moskau halten manöver auch in
chinas ningxia ab das alles bedeutet
natürlich nicht dass singapur ein kriegs
treibender akteur ist ganz und gar nicht
es ist die eine sache sich gut mit den
usa zu verstehen aber eine ganz andere
sich schlecht mit china zu verstehen und
hier hat singapur sagen wir einen
gewissen vorteil 69 prozent der chinesen
haben ein positives bild von diesem
stadtstaaten modell deng xiaoping selbst
als beispiel für die umsetzung der
reformen die das heutige china zur
weltmacht gemacht haben
singapur ist nun mal so etwas wie eine
kombination aus der militärischen
berufung spaß und der historischen
neutralität der schweiz mit dieser
kombination konnte es zu einem großen
finanzmarktplatz einen zufluchtsort für
kapital und unternehmen aus aller welt
und dabei spielen sowohl stärke und
sicherheit als auch neutralität eine
wichtige rolle dies ist also das weniger
bekannte gesicht singapurs seine rolle
als starke militär macht wo es weniger
als sechs millionen einwohner zählt und
kleiner ist als berlin oder kanntest du
diese seite des weges bereits schreibt
doch in die kommentare was du von
singapur ist und ob du glaubst es andere
staaten wie zum beispiel teil waren
diese strategie kopier sollten wie immer
sind wir auf deine meinung zu diesem
thema schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe also
dass dieses video gefallen hat falls ja
gib uns bitte einen leichten fehler es
seinen freund und vergiss nicht das abo
mit glöckchen um keines unserer videos
maps zu verpassen und unterstützer
unserer arbeit betraut mit einer kleinen
spende über den linken der beschreibung
unter diesem video was gut und das bald
[Musik]